[Music]
hey this is Jeff John's
hi I'm gonna listen hi I'm cliff Chang
hi I'm Brian Azzarello
we're here at New York comic-con 2012
and this is Wonder Woman 101 one one's a
very complex character I think the
character is going to be a conic because
better for worse I think she represents
the best in in women and I think it's
actually even more than that she
represents the best of humanity
Superman's an alien Batman's sad and
Wonder Woman she's she's a god now the
thing I love about her is that she's a
paradox in many ways I love the idea of
a young woman who's born on this island
of Amazons raised on this island of
Amazons and told the outside world is is
a place you do not want to go she's
never been out there where everybody
else on the mascara has all the Amazons
came to this island but she was born
there so she has no experience with the
outside world coming into this world is
is a very interesting story you know
she's never seen twitter's and really
didn't have that on the Paradise Island
had special you know Greek food we would
use to contact the harpies and then she
sees our world and and is in wonder of
it really that's the to me that's what
the Wonder in Wonder Woman is it's not
that G super strong or that she can jump
over a building or anything it's the
Wonder she brings out is she comes from
a completely different world so there's
a more fantastic element to Wonder Woman
and I think again that that's that's
given her a different edge you know
wonderings about mythology in the way
that Batman's of a claim and Superman is
a [ __ ] science fiction one room is
interesting the right because there's a
lot of room
right the character we are building a
very confident impulsive good-hearted
person wonder woman's greatest strength
is their compassion and her muscles
Wonder Woman's strength strengths and
weaknesses it's like one of those
interview questions where they ask you
that and and you it's the same answer
she cares too much Wonder Woman's
weaknesses her compassion and her
muscles the greatest adversity for
Wonder Woman is it's the whole world I
mean that's when one dream is a great
fish out of water story as well because
here's a young woman who has never seen
man and the idea not only has she never
seen him she can pretty much kick all
their asses 1o ones greatest adversary
would be you know I think people's
misconceptions about superheroes and
women it'd be nice to see actually a
very big iconic 1.open villain created
and maybe you'll see one in a storyline
next year in Justice League Wonder Woman
does not have a greatest adversary yet
by the end of the second year though she
will have a hell of an adversary I think
for me the the quintessential Wonder
Woman story is her fighting Nazis I
think she really works you know really
well as a World War 2 character there's
something really beautiful about you
know about her in that time period and
fighting against you know this really
monolithic evil if I'm looking at the
beginning stories if the Jorge Perez run
from the 80s is that like that first
that whole run for that he did is the
building blocks in the foundation of you
know of what one woman is words that
people have done great takes on one one
doing and Greg rocketed I mean we could
take Gail Simone did a good tape if I
had to pick one quintessential one one
story I gotta say I really like I like
appliance doing right now
she's nuts second string to Superman a
bad night anymore with you know what
we're doing and the changes that were
you know doing a Wonder Woman you know
the fact that now she has this
sort of God mode we're putting her up
there
[Music]